and what can we learn about human nature
the human mind
from the victims of genocide so victor
frankl talked about
the ability to discover meaning and
beauty
even in suffering
is there something to be said about
you know in your studying of genocide
that you've learned about human nature
well
again i i don't
i have to say i come out of the study of
genocide with a very pessimistic view of
human nature
a very pessimistic view even on the
victim side even on the victim's side
i mean the victims will
eat their children
ukrainian case they have no choice
you know the victims will rob each other
the victims will
form hierarchies
within victimhood
so you see
let me give you an example again i told
you i was
working on majdanek
and there's uh
in my donut
at a certain point in 42
a group
of slovak jews were arrested
and uh santa madonnak
though slovak jews were grouped somehow
they they stuck together they were very
competent they were
you know many of them were businessmen
they knew each other
and for a variety of different reasons
within the camp
and again this shows you the diversity
of the camps and also you know these
images of black and white in the camps
are not very useful
they ruled the camp
i mean they basically had all the
important jobs in the camp
including jobs like beating other jews
and
persecuting other jews and persecuting
other peoples
which they did
and this polish guy who i mentioned to
you who wrote this memoir hated them
because of what they were doing
to the polls
right and the and and he you know he's
he's incensed
because aren't these supposed to be the
intervention
he says and look what they're doing
they're treating us
you know like dirt
and they do they treat them like dirt
so you know in this kind of work on my
donek there's certainly
parts of it
that you know we're inspiring
um you know people helping each other
people
trying to feed each other people giving
warmth to each other you know there's
some very heroic
uh polish women who end up having a
radio show called radio mydonic which
they put on every night in the women's
camp which is you know to raise people's
spirits
and they you know sing songs and do all
this kind of stuff you know to
to try to keep themselves from
you know the horrors that they're
experiencing around them
and so you do see that and you do see
you know human beings acting
um
[Music]
in support of each other
but you know
i mean primo levy is one of my
favorite writers about about the
holocaust and about the camps
and you know i don't i i don't think
primo levy saw anything
you know i mean he had pals you know who
who he helped and who helped him
i mean but he describes this this kind
of
you know terrible inhuman environment
which no one can escape really no one
can escape he ends up committing suicide
too i think because of his
his sense
of we don't know exactly why but
probably because of his sense of what
happened
in the camp i mean later he goes back to
italy becomes a writer and that sort of
thing so
i don't i don't
especially in the concentration camps
it's really hard to find
places like vikkle frankel where you can
say you know i am
moved in a positive way you know by what
happened
there were cases there's no question
people hung together they tried to help
each other but but you know they were
totally
totally caught
in this in this um
web of genocide
you